[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
where's that for to think earth Dear
John Hank it's a comedy podcast for me
and my brother John answer your
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon how you doin John
I'm doing well how are you
I'm good I just had some Thai food it's
beautiful outside it is a solid eight or
nine degrees and I'm wearing quite a
quite a coat my friend we should add
that it's eight or nine degrees
Fahrenheit
correct Celsius it's like negative 60
sorry to all the people who have this
bizarre this bizarre system of
calculating temperature where zero
degrees is cold and a hundred degrees is
very very dead Hank how are you doing
overall other than the cold things good
how's fatherhood it's good things are
good he's getting to be he really likes
me singing as far as I can tell he just
wants me to sing all the time and that
may just be me being like oh this is a
fantastic I get an excuse to sing in my
house all the time which I never had
before
but it seems to make him smile yeah I
have to say my children never loved the
sound of my singing voice but that may
ultimately be because nobody does I do
have a heart I do have a problem that
John I tend to sing him whatever song
just pops into my head so I'll be like
I'll be like singing Rocky Horror songs
maybe a little inappropriate being like
let's give him something to talk about
baby and I'm like like your big poops or
something not like what we're talking
about in the song Hank we should also
say that the 2016 project for awesome
was a tremendous success and thank you
to all the listeners of the pod who
contributed we raised more than 2 point
1 million dollars for charity and thanks
to everybody who was part of that it was
an amazing weekend we felt very grateful
for it and it distracted from the
not-so-great news from AFC Wimbledon I'm
sorry about your one nil loss but we'll
get to that eventually
all right would you like a short poem
for the day it's from Emily Dickinson
yeah sure
his poems often known as there is no
frigate like a book there is no frigate
like a book to take us lands away nor
any coursers like a page of prancing
poetry this traverse may the poorest
take without oppressive toll how frugal
is the chariot that bears a human soul I
just love a good poem about a book Hank
I love that books are still as Emily
Dickinson points out a very frugal
chariot to bear the human soul so I
thought I'd read that poem do you have
any questions from our listeners yeah
here's here's a song about frugal
chariots John
it's from Danya who asks dear Hank and
John I cannot throw out my frugal
chariots ever it doesn't matter if I
think it's a terrible frugal chariot or
if it's actually falling apart I can
never bring myself actually to dispose
of any of my beloved volumes of
frugality in their chariot isset II but
I have shelves full of old unsalvageable
frugal chariots which have become
unreadable what should I do
do I need to just get over this and
throw them out I may not survive this
ordeal just to bring death in here
somewhere
any dubious advice is needed Hank I
don't know if you've ever gone through
someone's house after they died in order
to figure out what to do with all of
their stuff but it is one of the least
fun things I have ever done and I have
done some unfun things so my advice to
Danya is to throw away your book so that
other people won't have to later I also
I want to find out what Danny is doing
to her books to make them so
unsalvageable and how many of them are
assumably reading them in the bath
that's why I'm reading them in the bath
yes I mean I've probably destroyed of
the books I own like three in my entire
and it has usually has to do with water
like like a water bottle opened up in my
backpack and I was like well this copy I
do look I I also hang on to a lot of my
books obviously and I have a very
difficult time letting go of them and it
can be a nice thing to be able to go
through old books and read your notes in
them or to remember the experience of
reading them there are lots of books
that I might want to reread someday but
I'm always try
to call the person I look up to most and
this is rosianna who always despite
being one of the best read people I know
never has more than 50 physical books at
a time
she only keeps 50 books well I don't
know I have such a I have such the
attachment there are so many books on my
shelf that I haven't read in more than
10 years but I'm just like I want you I
love you I you are such a great thing
that I yeah no I mean and like I think
that's fine if a physical object brings
you joy there's no reason to get rid of
it but if it's stressing you out then I
think there is a reason to get rid of it
and then there is also the consideration
of the the people who will come after
you
but I don't think that's necessarily
like a pressing concern for Dania which
you know on the upside you've got that
going for you yeah no I think I love a
question for you it's from Claudia but I
don't know that I know the answer to it
so I thought that I would ask it and see
if you do know the answer to it she
writes dear John and Hank if you have a
2d object and you look at it from the
side can you actually see it or is it
just invisible well first of all Claudia
you don't have a 2d object they don't
exist kempt exist but if it did exist
and you did put one of like one point of
vision on the edge of it it would be
invisible it would not exist it would be
impossible to have that happen with both
of your eyes at the same time but yeah
you don't though unless you do have a 2d
object in which I would step slowly away
because I don't like the idea of what
you have done with our dimensions I
don't know I feel like I feel like we
haven't been particularly good to three
dimensions maybe we don't deserve all of
them anymore Hank maybe at this point
humanity just hasn't earned that third
dimension and we should be reduced to to
two so that we are all invisible to each
other from the side it's gotta be real
hard to to breathe and function in that
universe John but we'll make it work
I've got another question John okay
it's from Hannah who asks dear Hank and
John so one of my greatest fears has
always been that I will somehow end up
on a desert island or kidnapped or
something and I'll be wearing my
contacts and it won't have my
glasses or contact solution with me and
I just have to wear these contacts for
the rest of my life
ya know I'm gonna stop you right there
Hank because this is also one of my
greatest fears so Hannah and I have this
in common and there is an easy solution
to it which is that you should never not
wear glasses get LASIK also is a
potential solution no never not wear
glasses that way even if you're on the
desert island and you you're like
glasses break you can use little like
palm fronds to like remake your glasses
and they would be very hip yeah or just
like make a monocle out of them right
you're like oh hello I'm posh desert
island man I've made a monocle with my
eyeglass piece and a bunch of strands of
palm very good you could have a real bad
fake British accent wonderful wonderful
future for you on the desert island this
is a multi-part question though Oakland
Hannah goes on to ask also did cavemen
need glasses also could animals use them
like Simon and Alvin and the Chipmunks
that is a good separate good good
separate question Simon from that one
that the Chipmunks does doesn't
apparently need glasses I may just be a
fashion choice so that he could be like
hey just to be clear right I'm the nerdy
one so they put these on me but but yes
I think that animals it's hard to tell
because you can't be like okay what
letter is that Jeffery the dog but there
are definitely animals that have worse
vision than other animals like beavers
have really bad eyesight lots of animals
that don't tend to use their eyes as
much have bad eyesight and it does take
a lot of you know sort of fine-tuning
evolutionarily to get to really sharp
vision so my guess is that there are a
lot of dogs out there who have bad
eyesight and and you're like why don't
you get the ball and it's like my dogs
always been really bad at getting the
ball it's like well maybe you're talking
these glasses but that's not actually a
thing that you can figure out it'd be
wonderful he could figure out how to
figure it out though I'm interested in
that can we give dogs LASIK don't get
dog LASIK I mean that's the last that's
the last thing we need to add to the
world of veterinary science and and of
course early humans did often need
glasses and that was just that but they
didn't have them and then you just make
it work that's my understanding anyway
that's kind of what I did when I was a
kid actually I had
really poor eyesight as a child and
often like an hour or two into summer
camp I would lose my glasses and then I
would have no glasses for three weeks
and I would just kind of make it work
yeah I also think that I don't there's
no way to test for this but my guess is
that people before I glasses and before
sort of modern modern ways of taking
care of ourselves and feeding ourselves
they died more if they didn't have good
eyesight and so overall the number of
people with good eyesight was was higher
because it was selecting for that we
were no longer selecting for that yeah
in general I would not have fared
particularly well in a prehistoric
humanity yeah I probably be dead too oh
no I would definitely be dead you would
have died at the age of like five I just
think like I don't have the like genetic
toughness that allows you to become a
successful early human I am extremely
susceptible to all physical and mental
health problems
what do you think made Simon's glasses
from Simon the Chipmunks did he have
like name-brand were they Ravens
well they're like did he did he get him
from from some mail-order place or they
seem very homemade well Hank as it
happens right now I am at the Alvin and
the Chipmunks Wikipedia which is
actually called monka pedia of course
because of course it's called mocha
pedia because they're chipmunks and also
because chipmunk movies love a good pun
like Alvin and the Chipmunks road chip
Alvin and the Chipmunks ship wrecked
they all have fantastic funds in them I
should also say then folks at Fox 2000
who made the Alvin and the Chipmunks
movies also made The Fault in Our Stars
in Paper Towns movie so I'm a little bit
biased but I do really like those movies
so so you know those people according to
the CGI films at monka pedia Alvin's
eyesight is extremely poor as he is
unable to see a toaster waffle fall
directly in front of him without his
glasses did you mean Simon when you said
Alvin I did I'm sorry I'm not that much
okay you got another question for us I'm
just gonna stay with monka pedia for a
moment if i can in alvin exclamation
point exclamation point exclamation one
in the chipmunks that was the first time
that Alvin is it's Alvin which one has
glasses again Simon that was the first
time that Simon wore glasses with blue
rims so that was an innovation usually
it's black rimmed glasses but they went
with blue rims in Alvin three
exclamation points and the Chipmunks
well I mean they don't you think that
Simon made that decision it's not it's
not clear to me how much creative input
Simon has into the films I my
understanding is probably not a lot
although I i have heard that Simon is
responsible for the title of the second
movie which was of course alvin and the
chipmunks
the Squeakquel oh well I mean he he is
he is the smart one
I am now at the Alvin and the Chipmunks
monka pedia
wiki and I have to say that the
unfollowing snow is a really wonderful
effect it is winter time but editions in
addition to that it's showing the four
sort of like main it or like reor or at
least four of the iterations of Alvin
and the Chipmunks and on the upper
left-hand corner of the background we
have what is probably the original
Abbott and the Chipmunks drawings and
they are fine and then there was a
slightly evolved version of that a
version of that where they look quite
quite nice and this is actually sort of
what I remember as a child and then on
the right hand side we have the CGI
versions which are very different from
each other one is much more
anthropomorphize than the other but both
are I find to be extremely unsettling
and I don't want to be in the same world
as them anymore so can we move on
unfortunately we can't because I've just
found out that there is an episode of
alvin and the chipmunks called For Whom
the Bell Tolls oh and I'm trying to
determine how similar it is to the
Hemingway novel and the answer seems to
be not that much but you would be
stunned by the complexity and length of
the individual episode explanations
her at monka pedia your number one
source for alvin and the chipmunks
trivia and information do you want to
know where Simon's name came from I mean
if it's a name that other that many
people it was a it came from Simon whoa
wall rancor well rock wall rancor I'm
not very good at names who is a
violinist and record producer from 1939
to 1955 were rung Kerr recorded music
for 20th Century Fox films until he
chose to enter the recording industry
independently co-founding Liberty
records one of the major acts who
recorded on Liberty records was Alvin
and the Chipmunks and so that's why they
named Simon Simon Theodore was named
after Theodore key Oh God was also a
co-founder of Liberty right so there you
go we've gone all the way down the Alvin
and the Chipmunks rabbit hole I'm so
excited about our new podcast Hank monka
pedia a guide to the guide to alvin and
the chipmunks I've better move away real
fast before I accidentally make another
Alvin and the Chipmunks joke and we
continue talking about this this
question is from Sonia who asked dear
Hank and John if one finds oneself in a
forest was no memory of how they got
there what is the correct course of
action to take
does she begin walking in the hopes that
she will stumble across some form of
civilization risking wandering away from
it or should one remain in the spot
where she is in a hope of rescue again
she has absolutely no memory of the
forest or how she may have gotten there
or whether she came alone or not please
help as this question is bothering me I
hope it's just bothering you because
it's just like you you are afraid that
this unlikely circumstance will occur
and not because you are currently
emailing us from the forest if so I have
some unfortunate
if you got if you got a data connection
you're gonna be ok I know that I always
think of dear Hank and John is the
number one source for wilderness
survival tips so I'm excited to find out
what you think Hank but of course I know
that if you find yourself in the middle
of a forest you should just end you
don't know how you got there you should
just give up everyone knows that just
give in uh speaking of giving in John do
you want to know a sad story about
giving in yes sorry I am right now on
the manga pedia page for Simon's
alternate identities and did you know
that in the original Alvin and the
Chipmunks TV show there was a Cinderella
episode where Simon plays the fairy
godmother John I didn't know that about
Simon being the fairy God bunk but you
interrupted my my intro into this story
I wanted to tell about hopelessness and
giving up
okay great please tell me well so you
remember in 1980 when I hadn't been born
yet or I had just barely been born and
mount st. Helens erupted I do
well the some scientists had had a
pretty good idea that this was gonna
happen and they had closed down the park
around Mount st. Helens and for the most
part there was nobody nearby but a
couple of people had decided that they
were going to not heed those warnings or
that they were scientists or adventurers
or photographers and they were going to
go and document as the impending
eruption arrived and one guy I can't
tell you his name because I've forgotten
it was there he saw the the eruption
beginning he took some photographs of it
he took some photographs until he could
no longer see and then realizing that he
was not going to escape he he unwound
the film put it in its canister put the
canister in his backpack and then laid
down on his backpack so that the film
would stay safe so that people could see
the photographs that he took and then he
lay there and died and was covered in
ash and found 17 days later right I
remember that story it's very very sad
and I don't know why you felt like you
had to tell it on our podcast dear Hank
and John when we could have been making
very happy monka pedia jokes and now
we're in a dark place well at least we
got those photos it is kind of a
beautiful story but at the same time I
do wish that no one d had died in the
Mount st. Helens disaster Hank what do
you actually do if you're in a forest
and you don't know where you are don't
you stay still and wait for
skew III you would make a base camp
where you are and make some sign of
where you went in fact there was another
guy and his name I do remember because
his name was Dave Crockett and he he his
car got trapped as he was trying to
drive away and he marched off and he
wrote on his car door in the ash like
went uphill and and he managed to manage
to outrun the ash flow and and survived
so if you are Dave Crockett and in fact
you can go on YouTube and you can listen
to the video blog he made back in 1980
where he's talking to the camera about
how he thinks he's going to die it's
very eerie and then he figures that he's
gonna be okay and he's very happy I feel
so weird like we have suddenly inhabited
opposite consciousnesses like we're in a
Freaky Friday situation or something
because you're the one who's obsessively
talking about extreme darkness and all I
want to do is tell you an astonishing
fact that you cannot possibly be ready
for which is that in the eighties
Chipmunks show there was an episode
where they recreated Star Trek yeah now
I believe that I think I may have seen
that one it was called Star Trek the
absolutely final frontier and Simon has
played mr. speck there was also a
spin-off of Robocop of Robo Monk
where Simon played dr. Simon eyes some
of these puns are not very good and
there was a spin-off of splash called
sploosh in which Simon played trusty and
a spin-off of Batman in which Simon
played batmunk / Brice Wayne that's not
even a pun as far as I can tell no it
doesn't feel like at a certain point in
the eighth and final season of the 80s
chipmunks television show it does feel
kind of like they were giving up but
let's move on Hank to another question
from our listeners this one is from
Louise who asks dear Hank and John do
Santa and his elves have the right to
make trademarked products because you
asked for
from Santa and it's like okay but isn't
that made by nerf and not by the elves
right
that's a great question and the answer
is of course that Santa can do whatever
Santa wants to do well he has a deal he
has a deal with nerf and nerf has
factories that make nerf guns and then
Santa has the exact same capabilities as
those factories only at the North North
Pole with elves correct and he has a
view with all the major companies
he even has a deal with like you know
Mac or Apple and and West Western
Digital the people who make hard drives
like he's got a deal with every single
company it's pretty remarkable he's got
a deal dftba as soon as we started up a
company he was like okay well we you
know Santa at the at the North Pole also
has to make this these products so that
so that when a child asks Santa for them
he can make them and so we'd you know
sign up sign up to do that it's a little
bit of an uncomfortable licensing
conversation of course because you can't
go into it the way you would with a
normal life in seing partner on account
of how you know like we all love Santa
but we found a solution that works for
us and and it's been great and I know
that every company in the world is
similarly did you know that
Alvin of alvin and the chipmunks
actually has a last name oh my god it's
Seville like the I believe that's Bane
that's because it's cuz Dave's last name
is Seville but why is Dave's last name
Seville
he said knowing that the answer is
somewhere on monka pedia oh god it's
almost like I know more than you about
about Alvin and the Chipmunks not for
long but not at this hour okay this
question is from Hannah I'm gonna ask a
question from Hannah while you look up
why Dave Seville's left him in Seville
dear Hank and John yeah I have a
difficult decision to make in my career
I am a software engineer and I'm
currently interviewing for a job as a
build engineer which is a non-coding
role that requires slightly less
technical expertise at least in my field
the build engineer job sounds boring and
unfulfilled but for some reason the
salary is $12,000 more than my current
job a huge increase for me I'd be able
to pay off
student loans a year early two years
instead of three years Hana - incredibly
impressive being able to pay off your
student loans in two years or three
years yeah have you been paying them up
for the last 25 years like the rest of
us two years instead of three years and
finally move on with my life no you can
move on with your life before you pay
off your student loans - like that like
there there are things that you don't
have to be completely tied down I don't
think there are other things that you
could do anyway my question my question
is this should I willingly accept a
boring job for significantly more money
I really feel like I will be selling out
by taking a non programming job also my
drive to work would be 15 minutes longer
why didn't you stay start out with that
no no don't take a job that you're gonna
like less that's gonna put you in a car
for 30 minutes times 365 days a year at
no it's not that many it's more like 250
but still Hana I'd like to tell you a
story I'd like to tell you a story about
a man named Ross bag bag - sorry and
senior Ross also faced a choice when he
got home from World War two he faced a
choice between going and living a normal
life and having a normal job and
following his passion which was to speed
up the sound of his own voice using a
voice recorder that he had bought and
sing songs in a voice that sounded like
a chipmunk voice Ross had been stationed
in Seville Spain during World War two by
the way do you know the choice that he
made did he make the choice to take the
non programming job that paid somewhat
more but only for a little while and who
knows what the future holds and if you
are making a living doing what you love
to do and 15 and saving 30 minutes a day
isn't that wonderful
that's he made the choice I'm sorry I
lost myself in trying to make the
connections here but the point is that
he chose to follow his dreams which were
not like totally random dreams they were
the completely realistic dreams of a man
who just wanted to make a
singing with a sped-up voice that
sounded like chipmunks and he did it he
did it Hana he did it and that is the
whole reason that we have alvin and the
chipmunks the Squeakquel the whole
reason that we have alvin and the
chipmunks shipwrecked the whole reason
that we have alvin and the chipmunks the
road chip which for a while I think also
had the tentative name okay planes
trains and automobiles so I think the
answer here is very clear Anna that if
you're making a living doing something
that you like and find fulfilling that
you will over time find more
opportunities in that and an extra year
paying off your student loans is not
going to be a huge deal in the scheme of
things that is my opinion I think you
should go to monka pedia look up Ross
Bagdasarian senior and just be inspired
just be inspired as I have been well I
do I did the math and and and and I do
want to say that just by if you're if
you're spending that time and extra time
at a car that's about a hundred and
twenty five hours per year that you'll
be the extra spending in that car for
$12,000 so it's about a hundred dollars
an hour to drive to your job so that's
not nothing but it's not a job you want
to take don't take it do the things that
you want to do I mean the only advantage
Hank is that it does make it more likely
that Hanna will continue to be a
listener of dear Hank and John if she's
spending more time in the car every day
that's very true additionally it also is
sometimes especially if you can move
back like if there's some potentially
out Li for you to be like I don't like
this that much like it's gonna connect
please go back to my old job it might be
interesting to see if you do actually
like this job as a build engineer more
you you don't actually know how whether
you're gonna like it or not until you do
it
and I don't think that it's like selling
out to to not be on the ground doing the
thing you might just be doing a
different thing that you also like and
that's that's also interesting I
definitely wouldn't I worry about people
being like but like they're like I want
to be I want to be on the ground doing
the thing but also like organizing
people to do the thing is a different
kind of doing the thing and also an
important part of doing the thing so I
wouldn't I wouldn't discount it just
because you
think that it's not like the the work
that you have previously in your life
sort of I like like idolized as like
this is the work that I should be doing
you don't really know and and there will
always be new paths being laid out in
front of you and you get to choose which
of those paths you go down and and and
choosing before you know which paths are
there I think is is something that
causes a lot of people stress and
anxiety and and also gets them locked
into stuff right but it sounds like
Hannah knows what she wants to do with
her life she knows that she likes
working and programming and I would
encourage her to continue doing that
maybe though you can always try the
strategy of going into your boss and
saying I have a I have another job offer
it's for 12 grand more can ask Weezy for
a little bit extra but I don't know I'm
not an expert in that hand I don't want
you to get fired or any well it may be
it may be that this is at the same
company is what I was assuming well I
mean who knows Hank the point is that if
you look at the career of Ross
Bagdasarian senior I think you have a
good model for how to build a good life
inside of tech companies as well that is
that is a good point this podcast of
course is brought to you by Ross
Bagdasarian the creator of Alvin and
chipmunks also defender of Liberty in
World War two defender of Seville and
and defender of the idea that you can
accomplish anything if you have a vision
and just a tiny tiny bit of modern
technology and of course this podcast is
also brought to you by Ross Bagdasarian
jr. who has kept the Chipmunks dream
alive oh thanks for us thanks Ross
podcast is also brought to you by Santa
strong-arming small businesses into
great licensing deals since the
beginning of time I'm just kidding Santa
this licensing deal is actually very
very beneficial which is why everybody
signs up to do it that's exactly right
and of course lastly this podcast is
brought to you by frugal chariots frugal
chariots available now at your local
independent frugal chariot store you
know Chad we actually have a real
sponsor this week and that is nerdcon
nerdfighteria the event that we are
running and going to be
and I know that it's weird that it's not
it's not actually a sponsorship because
we're not paying ourselves but we would
love if you would be interested in
coming up to nerdcon nerdfighteria well
we will be recording a live episode of
dear Hank and John we will be hanging
out doing all kinds of other things Q&A
s and being on panels and there's gonna
be a bunch of cool people there like
nathan zed and charlie mcdonnell and and
many others which you can find out at
nerdcon nerdfighteria and it's in
February in Boston and you can get
tickets at nerdcon nerdfighteria comm
hey can I ask you another question in
February 25th and 26th in Boston
Massachusetts and tix tickets are $60
please come we'd love to see you yes you
can ask me another question
alright Hank we have a question from
Barbara in Germany who asks dear John
and Hank in the last few months I've had
some mental health issues with help I'm
slowly getting better but as I do get
better I've started to ask myself why me
am I not as strong as others take care
Barbara I am familiar with that feeling
and also with the feeling of oh if I
were just a little bit more mentally
strong I wouldn't have to deal with this
and I think some of that is received
from messages in the culture but I also
think some of it is probably you know
your brain talking to you in a way
that's not kind or generous different
people have to deal with different
things in their lives different people
have different sets of problems and you
have yours and comparing yourself to
other people or constructing your
illness as weakness I don't think is
helpful in the end I think having a
mental illness doesn't mean that you're
weak any more than having any other
illness means that you're weak all it
means is that you're sick and you need
treatment and you need to get better and
focus on that rather than on the
sickness it's very difficult to deal
with the why me question because it's
always there I think it's there for
people who have any kind of illness but
but I find that trying to focus on being
well and getting well and taking good
care of myself and being nice to myself
is helpful on those fronts think that
was a good answer
I've got another question from an
anonymous Oscar are anonymous questioner
and I like this question and I think
that it's fascinating and I have been
I've been wondering when it was going to
happen and so here it is you're Hank and
Shawn first know that I am a fan and
generally love everything you do I may
however have one issue which is it seems
that John has a personal vendetta
against my father's place of employment
jardin zinc products you see oh the
number one maker they make leave any
blanks for the US Mint
being a fan I have listened to countless
discussions from John about the penny
and don't even necessarily disagree that
the penny is bad for the economy however
I am very Pro penny for a very selfish
reason my dad is old enough that he
would have a hard time finding gainful
employment at a place he has not worked
for 35 plus years so my question is and
I think this is the biggest question as
well how do we reconcile the things that
we agree with in principle when the
result of that principle would lead to a
major personal loss it's one thing to
say that we have to be willing to
compromise the good of the many for the
few yeah I mean this is a really
interesting difficult question Hank and
I have run into this a few times in our
own careers and lives most notably when
the US Congress was debating a bill that
would have made it very complicated and
expensive for dftba.com to continue to
do business because of the complexities
of local sales tax in the United States
the consumption taxes in the US are not
national they are they are they are by
state or by city or by county there are
literally thousands of different sales
taxes in the United States so if and
when a tailor's like dftba.com have to
calculate sales tax it's just going to
be a huge expense on them on the other
hand not having to pay sales tax means
that companies like dftba.com don't
contribute to the places where our goods
are purchased which is not fair so Hank
and I are in favor of us people paying
sales tax
on stuff they buy online even though it
is not in our best interest however we
are also coming at all of this from an
extremely privileged position that's
different from the position that your
dad is in in making that consideration
because it dftba.com is not the only way
that - Hank and I you know have of
making a living so I also think that
we're running up against this on a much
larger scale in the way that we're
talking about globalisation like we know
that globalization has been good for the
economy overall we know that it's
created lots of jobs both inside the
United States and outside of it but we
also know that it is probably part of
what's increasing the global disparity
of wealth it's part of what's increasing
the number of people who feel left
behind in the economy and and that
wealth inequality is bad it's not it's
not just like ethically bad it's bad for
the economy it's it's bad for the
cohesiveness of social institutions it's
just objectively bad so you've got a
balance that knowledge with wanting you
know an efficient well-run economy which
in my opinion would involve no pennies
yeah yeah and this is a and I think in
particular like I would like to think
that there's a world where like you know
there are people need zinc for stuff and
and if you know yeah but not on that
scale Hank like I mean that's the thing
like on some levels a lot of pennies
right we have we have this all over our
economy pennies are one example but we
have lots of examples of this right we
spend way too much money on health care
well spending way too much money on
health care creates jobs it creates lots
of jobs and lots of fairly high paying
jobs relative to a lot of the economy
but we spend way way way too much of our
total economy on health care so if we
were to make that more efficient and
have a healthcare spending level that
was closer to say Australia or Canada or
France or Germany or literally anywhere
else on
earth then there would be a lot of jobs
lost than a lot of those jobs would be
good jobs that would be lost and so it's
really difficult I don't I don't know is
my only answer like I don't know how to
manage that I don't know how to you know
I don't know and I and I love your
question and we wanted to read it
because we loved it not because we have
answers correct I I also have but just
done a little bit of research John the
company that owns this penny like making
operation also owns one of your favorite
companies in the world John really the
makers of the Sharpie pen oh god I love
sharpies I mean I don't understand why I
don't have a brand deal with diet dr.
pepper and sharpies it is totally unjust
to me I how is it that I'm able to have
a wonderful and fulfilling corporate
relationship with my friends at the Mars
company maker of my personal candy bar
Snickers and not have a relationship
with diet dr. pepper and the people at
sharpie
I signed a hundred and fifty thousand
copies of The Fault in Our Stars with
sharpies I should have I should be able
to get some free sharpies out of that
man I'm still paying for my sharpies
Hank I go to CVS and I buy my own
sharpies and I feel like I should be
getting them for free I really do Oh
John I just had a thought
yeah what if we could create some
something that the economy would be
really really into yeah that would cost
more than a penny but it would use the
penny blank that the US Mint had stopped
using to create new pennies so like we
just need to create a product that
people are gonna be really into and
they'll buy a lot of and they'll cost
like 2 or 3 cents so that the so that we
can get rid of pennies but then people
will have a product that they will love
and want to be a part of their lives and
will bring them satisfaction and
continue to have people consuming these
these things that are already being made
what is that if we just asked it let's
like marbles like it should be a game
that just sweeps the nation and it's
there's gonna there's a dance that goes
with it but is it gonna be a game that
sweeps the nation
like 200 million penny blanks are gonna
be used every year I just I don't know I
appreciate your enthusiasm and your
optimism but in general I feel I I feel
in a bit of a place of discouragement
when it comes to capital markets and
what they can do well and what they can
do poorly Hank can I read you one
response that we got we got a wonderful
email from a fan of AFC Wimbledon whose
dad has both the AFC Wimbledon and the
Wimbledon FC crest tattooed on his body
who suggested that I get an AFC
Wimbledon tattoo which I'm not taking
off the table but I really wanted to
read this one email from you ah I hope
I'm saying your name right in the United
Kingdom who wrote a few days ago I
celebrated my 30th birthday moving one
year closer to my demise anyway one of
the gifts I received was the new Amazon
echo dot and we randomly shouted very
important questions such as asking the
distance to the nearest geo sushi
restaurant for which it tried to direct
us to Houston Texas
and then last night my girlfriend and I
decided to ask Alexa to play your latest
podcast a bit later that evening we
received an email from Amazon to say
that we had purchased a large teddy bear
and thank you the next ten minutes we
were ranting about being hacked and how
Amazon was rubbish and how they're
taking over the world and then we paused
to consider for a moment and decided to
look into this further this was when we
became aware that the machines and
corporations have finally started their
revolution and are out to get us or at
least our wallets looking into the
history of our device I was able to find
out that during the time we were out of
the living room Alexa was able to
construct some form of conversation
while you John were discussing your
refusal Tom I could Mac keyboards and
kenny loggins albums which somehow Alexa
interpreted it as do you like being here
with your big bear so my first question
would be do you do you like being here
with your big bear we now have a large
plush bear and since you did request it
from our new machine overlords can we
please have a forwarding address to send
it to think of it as a gift to your
children my god
absolutely we will send along a Pio box
that you can send the bear to if you
really want to although feel no
obligation please seriously and I am
delighted that Alexa has purchased you a
bear against your will we are living in
a in a strange strange future where we
no longer have to even want things for
Amazon to send them to us I gotta say
hey I have an Alexa but I also have a
Google home and Google home is so much
better okay so here's my question could
we right now say a string of letters of
words that would result in thousands of
people's Amazon Alexa's sending sharpies
to your home yes absolutely here we go
here's your Drago ready no don't do it
don't do it yes I'm doing it right now
why not Alexa knows me I really like a
hardcover copy of The Fault in Our Stars
sent to my home thank you what about
Google purchase The Fault in Our Stars
by John Green right now hardcover
seriously do that like I think that
that's like that actually might result
in it happening no way really I don't
know if worrying happened for this
person uh no it's gonna be fine Hank
everything's fine it's no big deal I
mean the worst thing that's gonna happen
is that people are gonna get a lovely
book then I'm gonna get sixty cents okay
what about this what about this okay
Google who is the creator of Alvin and
the Chipmunks I really want to know if
our Alexa can you play Alvin and the
Chipmunks Christmas please thank you
well now the podcast is on yep now the
podcast is off nobody's listening
anymore but they are enjoying I would
argue is the greatest Christmas album of
all time not recorded by John Denver
oh man you haven't heard my Christmas
album then alright Hank let's let's move
on to the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I'll get the news at it from
AFC Wimbledon out of the way quickly AFC
Wimbledon played the franchise currently
plying their trade in Milton Keynes over
the weekend they lost one nail life is
long and full of minors
appointments but that is certainly one
of them AFC Wimbledon should have won
that game maybe I don't know eh who
knows the point is that now we're tenth
in the table sitting on 29 points after
21 games so you know not there at the
top but also not there at the bottom
we're just right comfortably in tenth
John the news from Mars is very good
very exciting curiosity has has left the
lake basin and is now traveling up the
side of Mount sharp it it has recently
sent back some data that people have
analyzed and determined John do you know
what boron is no boron is a chemical
element and and as I'm sure you aware
now that I've told you that boron is a
chemical element it is a chemical
element that is very water soluble and
but but it is it is water soluble in
neutral water so it doesn't like super
alkaline water doesn't like super acidic
water and it is clear that there was
that there was a ton of groundwater
moving around in the Mount sharp Basin
after the lake just even after the lake
disappeared so there this lake existed
for a long time but then there was an
active groundwater system that was
moving elements around and it was pH
neutral like close to pH neutral so this
is like perfect conditions for life not
just that as the Curiosity has been
traveling up the side of the mountain
the composition of the rocks have
changed which means that that there are
chemical gradients on Mars so there are
areas that are different like like
substantially different geologically
from nearby areas which is like also a
great condition for life because it
means that that life could be carried
like like could be feeding off of those
chemical differentials and then finally
we have like this groundwater situation
is making us think that the horizon for
when Mars was a nice place for life for
when there was liquid water and it was
warm neutral pH neutral liquid water
could
been in the hundreds of millions of
years which on earth by by hundreds of
millions of years in earth-like earth
life was happening so I just want to
advocate because there's only so much
that robots can do though I'm in favor
of them doing more if we could get
humans to Mars by like I don't know 2027
it would be an amazing opportunity to
find what might be a completely unique
like ecosystem based on different
biologies that probably doesn't exist
anymore it may exist in very small
pockets probably doesn't exist anymore
but but I'm starting to feel like
probably did exist and that's a weird
crazy thing for me to say because I have
not been super like into exobiology but
like the the conditions for life were
very good for a very long time on the
surface of Mars it seems and this is all
information that we never would have had
if it hadn't been for curiosity doing
great work and the scientists doing
great work with that data and what a
what a fantastic mission curiosity now
and it's I think third year on the
planet has been has been accomplishing
it's so so fantastic the kinds of stuff
we've been learning from this mission
well Hank I'd like you to explain to me
why it's so important to do this by 2027
if the life is in all likelihood already
gone and will be equally gone in say
2028 you know I think it's just I don't
have to explain myself to you
all right Hank what did we learn today
Oh God I mean learn what do you mean you
don't know he learned so much about
Chipmunks we did we learned a lot about
Ross Bagdasarian and also Simon and
Theodore at Liberty records and and the
color of Simon's glasses and they're
increasing progression into creepier and
creepier forms as as 3d technology has
gotten better for some reason it only
makes chipmunks worse
we also learned that if you are found in
the middle of the forest you should take
pictures then put the film in your
backpack roll up onto it and get covered
by layers of volcanic ash that is of
course terrible advice like everything
in our podcast we also learned that if
you are looking at a 2d object you
should be concerned
yes very concerned and finally we
learned that Santa is a extraordinarily
accomplished business person in addition
to being one of the most giving and
sweet entities upon this earth I know
Hank there is so much to be discouraged
about in this world but there is also
much to be encouraged about thank you
for potting with me thanks to everybody
for listening thanks to Nicholas Jenkins
for editing the podcast rosianna halse
rojas and victoria bon giorno help out
as well our theme music is by gunnarolla
you can email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com or check us out on Twitter at
Hank green and John Green and of course
ah did I say our theme music is by gonna
roll up because it is even if I said
that twice on that on that proud of it
thanks again for listening and as we say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]